one of the things that we'd often ask
each other at the beginning of the
process was what do you see what do you
experience a lot in life
but you never see it on television and
that's often a place that i find very
fruitful to write
from and i remember there's this moment
in the last episode of the show where
she's where she's
quite unpleasant to her son and i
remember standing around the
monitor when we when we were filming it
and and somebody going oh god that's
horrible and then and i said oh is it is
it is that what your experience
of that is and she said yeah i said no
it's possible oh yeah there was you said
yes
but the other mothers around the monitor
or when i said yeah but have you ever
do you so you're saying you never would
talk like that to your son and they went
oh no yeah i do all the time i just mean
it's it's horrible
on screen and it's moments like that
where you go
oh brilliant brilliant then this is what
we want because you've got all these
people going oh yeah oh yeah at least
once a week but not on television
and that's the moment i'm interested in
really i wanted to ask you as well
because
i think that there's a there's such a
brilliant honesty that you can see
in in the portrayal of the character and
whether
you know she's obviously someone who's
in the public eye and she's someone
who's been in the public eye
for a young age but you can also you
know just look at her on a human level
sort of thing as well
but i think that one of the things
that's brilliant is peeling back that
kind of
veneer of celebrity in a way you know in
terms of showing her as a mother
to uh to you know a young boy who
um who is uh is deaf
and and you know and and having you know
not everything being right and and was
it important for you to have the chance
to kind of do that in a way you know
being someone who's been in the public
eye from a young age and you know
there's nothing you know biographical
about this but i imagine quite a lot of
your experience is kind of poured into
so much of this show
yeah i think it's just for me as an
an actor it's just it's just important
that
um women are represented on screen
whether they're
playing a famous person or just
you know or a mother or someone whatever
it is
it really spins me out when
that is done inauthentically i i really
passionately hate it and i feel
it's such a wasted
a wasted moment and so for me just the
quest to
constantly um drive through to um
something that feels you know at times
horribly honest um and you know
potentially very exposing but
i i think you know i both lucy and i i
think
share this sort of quest which is we we
want to
we want to be we want people to be able
to relate to it and i think
one of our concerns at the beginning was
oh she's it's we were using a
we're drawing from a famous person's
life but actually
on some level nowadays we all have
something to lose because we all have a
very
weirdly we have this now public profile
yeah um just by being on social media
really i think
um everything you know anything could be
incriminating
on some level and um
it was important that for us that when
people
watch that it's not distancing
um as an experience that it's something
that they can relate to so certainly all
the emotional stuff was really you know
integral and um yeah
yeah yeah i think um one of the things
that we'd often ask each other
at the beginning of the process was what
do you see what do you experience a lot
in life
but you never see it on television and
that's often a place that i find very
fruitful to write
from and i remember there's this moment
in the last episode of the show where
she's where she's
quite unpleasant to her son and i
remember standing around the
monitor when we when we were filming it
and and somebody going oh god that's
horrible and then and i said oh is it is
it
is that what your experience of that is
and she said yeah
i said no it's probably oh yeah there
was you said yes but the other mothers
around the monitor all
when i said yeah but have you ever do
you so you're saying you never would
talk like that to your son and they went
oh no yeah i do all the time i just mean
it's it's horrible
on screen and it's moments like that
where you go
oh brilliant brilliant then this is what
we want because you've got all these
people going oh yeah oh yeah at least
once a week
but not on television and that's the
moment i'm interested in
that's so true there are yeah absolutely
well i think that's about the whole
thing about the emotional truth that you
get from the show
to be honest um lucy was it important
for you to be
kind of you know were you there whilst
the whole thing was being filmed sort of
thing is that
yeah but i'm you know i'm a controlling
nightmare i mean i'm i'm constantly mad
like i'm like
that was a note to me lucy
no i mean yeah yes i am i'm no i can't
excuse it but you know it's it's how you
you know i don't know i just worked
really hard on it and i didn't want the
arty without me you didn't want to miss
out on the fun did you that's the thing
do you know how boring writing is
compared to that it's so
boring was there was a kind of
encouragement to
or did you have this to the time and
space to to improvise on set or to kind
of play with scenes and
georgie was that something that you were
interested in in looking into or
or not i love it i mean i've sort of got
an ephos of actors which is like
let them own the character you know and
then and then i want to guide them
through
the world but i don't want to tell them
who they are like let them really own it
and
believe it's like a master class of that
i learnt so much from her because that's
a general mo
you know and um i think so then
yeah yes yes and no you know it was
always lucy was always there so we just
we we talked about those things there's
certain scenes where
it would spin off i mean i think all of
the actors hate me because i never say
cut
and i'm just forcing them to at the end
of every day there's always something
brilliant because they just have to keep
going like billy i remember once when
you were like
i can see you like she's gonna [ __ ]
say it
yeah i was like she's like oh god
there's only so much improving i can do
but what it does is it like allows this
sort of like
beautiful and i'm always looking for
like the kind of extra just letting them
really
building a space so however technical we
get and however
um orchestrated something gets the what
i always want to do is make sure that
the actors don't feel that and that they
have the ultimate freedom to just really
like play and i don't mind if it's
different every time
in fact i encourage that it's like focus
bullets hate me because i won't allow
marks to go down i don't want to block
it but i
but within that there's a really grand
master plan and i think
improv sort of played in and out of that
it had to work for this
for the episode so episode six for
example which is
guilt and is based upon for me
stylistically and
kind of much more of a social realism
vibe
it plays a little bit more with the day
players in terms of improv
and so yeah yes to a certain extent
where it was right but it always came
back down to the central right i mean
lucy probably wrote the show you don't
like the words are always brilliant and
then you
you know we explored beyond that a
little bit here and there
i am that photo shoot in the first
episode
is is an extraordinary piece of
of film it's just you know those those
shots of your face
billy in terms of you you just see
it's so emotional it's so hard to watch
but you can't not
watch it because you yeah it's
it's so great congratulations on that
alone because i just thought it was
extraordinary
oh thanks let me talk about comic-con
yeah yes so you actually went
to comic-con is this right yeah we went
to
we went to the i i i forget the official
name of it now but the london
comic-con and we we took over uh
we took over a space and um we had our
own
set up with our own big poster in the
background of courvardes and our own
audience and our own
um you know strange sci-fi costumes and
our own hosts um lucy didn't decide
herself
to be honest with you i'm a sci-fi fan
so i was there
going like i this is this is the show i
want to make this pretend
though that we've done all this design
for with philly's massive face on
um and uh that's not true
and it was it was yeah that was really
fun and we also had a lot of fun i think
um
leila the like was in when we did that
scene in the hotel room we got an actual
hotel
obviously to do it in but you know the
idea being it was attached to comic-con
and i we i think that was one of our one
of our best
one of our finest hours actually that
whole section i don't know what um
i don't know but yeah that was
sorry it's like 101 dalmatians
um yeah so
so it was it was really really really
fun to do um
i think it was quite fun to act as well
am i wrong yeah
the hotel room was a lot of fun i mean i
had a great time
[Music]
you